you know i tell people when i get sick i
want to be treated
but i'd rather just not get sick and uh
i think it's going to be easier to slow
aging than it is to treat most of these
diseases of aging
so hello and welcome to the chicky
science show where in this video i had
the absolute pleasure to interview
professor brian kennedy who is currently
working at the national university of
singapore
at the center for healthy aging where
his lab is using multiple animal models
combined with human studies
to understand the mechanisms driving
biological aging
and to develop interventions designed to
extend health span and lifespan
prior to this position brian was the
president and ceo
of the bach institute for research and
aging in california
in this interview we discuss brian's
interests current work and excitement
for future research avenues
so i hope you enjoy it but first it's
time to de-animate right
so hi brian thank you very much for
taking the time to talk with me today
and say welcome to the cheeky science
show
so i believe that you're joining me
today from singapore
and so um we'll talk about the work that
you're doing there
later on in this interview and some of
the exciting clinical trials that you're
conducting
but you've also got a very impressive
track history of research that you've
done for your career so far
and so i guess my first question is
what got you into the field of aging
where did that
initial interest come from and to you
what is the aging process how would you
define ageing
yeah i think well thanks for inviting me
first of all it's pleasure to be here
and
and we're right in the middle of a
thunderstorm so if you hear loud noises
that's why
um you know i think there's two answers
to why i got into aging
and one was that i was an only child
and i grew up and um sort of with
all of my older relatives lived forever
i mean both of my grandmothers reached
one of them was 99 when she died in the
other 101
and so i got to watch a lot of people go
through the aging process that were
close to me
people were different states of health
the one grandmother was very healthy she
lived a lower all the way to 101
and the other one had everything wrong
and and different attitudes and so i was
just curious about what causes aging
i mean everybody says oh it's just
natural but to me
and that doesn't make it good right so
you know
i was curious about it and then when i
got to graduate school
uh another graduate student and i nick
ostriaco
joined lenny guarente's lab at mit and
uh we wanted to work on yeast cells but
we wanted to pick the craziest thing we
could think of to do with these cells in
the
time there were two choices one was
aging and one was apoptosis
and apoptosis seemed too crazy because
we were talking about a single-celled
organism undergoing programs held death
and so we chose aging and that started
the whole process
the funny part of that though is that
the other graduate student became a
priest
and then he became a priest biologist
and it has a little lab and he studies
apoptosis in east through
the whole field on that too i guess we
would have been okay either way
um if you want how how i think about
aging i think that
it's really funny because the field is
made a lot of progress in some areas
we've come up with numerous
interventions
that might slow aging more recently
we've identified
and by we i mean the whole field has
identified biomarkers of the aging
process
that are extremely useful i think that
when like 30 years ago when i started in
the field everybody thought
well it'll be relatively easy to
understand mechanistically what causes
aging but to do interventions will be
really really difficult and now we've
got all these interventions and i still
don't think we really understand what
mechanistically is causing aging
uh so it's a bit of a surprise and the
way i think about it
is that you know aging is not just one
thing
it's not dna damage it's not this folded
proteins it's a combination of things
and they can be read out in different
hallmarks or pillars of aging
inflammation adult stem cell function
metabolism
macromolecular damage all of those
things
but what's really happening to me is
that
as you get older you have a homeostatic
network in your body that keeps you
healthy
and it responds to the damage that's
happening
to you uh and so yeah if it's somebody
who's 40 we can measure aging they don't
run as fast
you know they probably don't think quite
as fast if we do chemical assays
but they're still highly functional
they're still active they're still
you know um very much on top of
everything they do in their lives
what happens though is when enough
damage happens that network breaks down
and it can't compensate anymore then you
kind of spiral out of control
and depending on the risk factors you
have and your lifestyle
you start getting diseases so maybe
you'll get diabetes maybe you'll get
cancer or maybe you'll get
some sort of cognitive impairment or
some combination thereof
but to me the interventions that slow
aging are really maintaining that
network
and so then it becomes a systems biology
question why does intervening in the
torah pathway
preserve the network and i don't think
we have a
really good answer for that yet it's one
of those
challenges because the complexity of
that question is maybe beyond
uh the ability to reduce it to a simple
series of statements and so
the ai approaches may be very meaningful
in that regard
but i would just come back to say that i
don't think there's one cause of aging i
think there are lots of things that
drive aging some things are more
important
one into one set of individuals than
another
and the interventions seem to improve
all outputs of the network they reduced
inflammation they were improved
proteostasis
but but what their their immediate
effect is that's
this target causing aging to slow down i
think is still an open question
really good answer and i completely
agree i mean one of the things that
fascinates me most about
the aging process as a kind of
biochemist is just how complicated it is
and but also how everything seems to be
interconnected
and it just seems such an interesting
process to study
and so you spoke about interventions and
some exciting research that was
published last year
was on alpha-ketoglutarate which is an
endogenous metabolite that was shown in
this
i think it was a cell metabolism paper
to extend both
healthspan and lifespan in mice and so
um could you tell me a bit about what
alpha cubic glittery is and what that
research study found
yeah so this is a central metabolite if
you've had biochemistry you looked at
alpha ketoglutarate it's right in the
tca cycle
and actually it's at the interface of
protein catabolism and carbohydrate
metabolism so it's really
helps with metabolic flexibility it
helps the cell
you know convert if there's too many
proteins and not enough
carbohydrates or the vice versa it helps
to convert among those different
pathways
it can do a lot of things at the
cellular level akg is a substrate for
almost a thousand different reactions
in some ways it's a lot like nad you
know that it's it's just
involved in central metabolism it's
involved in many different reactions
the levels of akg go down with aging and
uh supplementing them back up seems to
have a beneficial effect
what we found is that if we start the
mice at 18 months of age it only extends
lifespan by about 10
but perhaps more importantly it reduces
frailty by 50
so what we think is happening is
compressing morbidity
shortening the time when you're sick and
if that
phenotype is preserved to humans uh
that's a really
exciting molecule because that's what
you really want right it's a lot as
healthspan as possible
and we're hopeful that akg might help
contribute to that
that effect and there's clinical studies
ongoing right now trying to address that
and so the other thing you noticed in
that study was that there seemed to be
sex specific differences
and so i was wondering if maybe
understanding why there were
specific differences could help to
understand the mechanism of action of
akg in the asian and aging interventions
you know i i think that you know it's
really interesting that all of the
interventions seem to have sex specific
effects
uh so akg works a little bit better in
females but it
frankly works in both rapamycin and
metformin seem to work better in females
17 alpha estradiol for instance works
better in males
and we don't really know why there's
been some studies now
and it seems to involve sex hormones as
one might expect
but i think there's a lot of work to be
done i assume that some of those
differences will be preserved in human
intervention studies as well so it
wouldn't be surprising as we start just
interventions
that some work better in males or
females um
and i think you're right that's a very
interesting clue to try to understand
mechanistically what's going on and it
also points to the role of
sex hormones in the aging process
exactly and so the other thing about in
that study
you use the calcium salt version of akg
and so i i think when the study came out
so i did some calculations to work out
the percentage of like calcium
as of by mass of calcium akg and so
as well as giving the mice akg they're
also getting quite a lot of calcium
and so i was wondering and to what
extent do you think calcium might be
influencing
the results or have you looked into that
we have now and
uh it seems like the you can get the
effects with other forms of akg
but the one challenge that i would bring
up is that
in in the mice we're putting akg in the
food and they're eating all day long
uh and at higher quantities in human
studies we're
using a sustained release version of the
pill and i think that's important
because we want to get it
more of it through the gut and create
more bioavailability so
especially if they're taking you know
less on
a per mass basis so our evidence
suggests that the time released version
of akg may be more beneficial in the
human context
that's something that we're testing uh i
don't think we have any support for the
idea that calcium itself
is generating the effects okay and so
you mentioned the human clinical trials
and so i believe that
there is in the works released in
process a human clinical trial at
singapore
looking at the effects of akg on a
variety of different aging biomarkers
and so um could you tell me a bit more
about the clinical trial where you're
currently at
and what different markers are you
trying to look at
yeah there are two clinical studies that
are that are
sort of in process uh one is using the
rejuvent product by the company and so
that's a
calcium akg sustain release plus a
vitamin for men it's vitamin name for
women it's vitamin d
that's what the product has and that's a
six month clinical study people 45 to 65
years old it's nearly
finished and i think it'll be finished
in the next three months
and we'll be able to start to really
look at the data
we're looking at methylation clock
as well as a number of clinical markers
inflammatory markers metabolic markers
etc
and we're really hopeful that we'll see
some beneficial effects
on biologic aging now we already know
that the
um that study is being conducted at
indiana university actually
we already know that um people that buy
the product we they can buy a
methylation test at the beginning and
they do a test four to six months later
and we are seeing a reversal of biologic
age in those individuals but that's not
a clinically controlled study i mean
it's
subject to placebo effects and
everything and so it'll be
really it's great that we're seeing that
but we want to see how much of that
translates through to the you know
controlled clinical study and then in
uh singapore what we're doing is a whole
series
right now we're doing cross-sectional
measures of biologic aging so we have
300 individuals
and we're measuring probably 10
different things that address
biologic age and we want to begin to
understand which of those work in
singapore ethnicities
but also uh to see how they relate to
each other so if the methylation clock
says you're old
you know we have another clock from 3d
facial reconstruction because i'd say
you're old as well
um because i don't want to spend five
thousand dollars to measure aging i want
to spend 200
but i'm not sure any one clock is
sufficient either so we need to know
where the overlap is
where the uniqueness is in these clocks
uh and then the next
then we're going to be doing this the
whole series of interventions one of
which is the sustain release calcium
alpha ketoglutarate
without the vitamins because here i want
to get more toward mechanism and not
have the complicating factor of the
vitamins
but we'll also test a number of other
supplements and lifestyle interventions
and the goal is really to
figure out which interventions work the
best in humans because i don't think
anybody
really knows the answer to that yet and
also to figure out which ones work and
which people maybe some interventions
work better in males or females or
or maybe things some people some things
don't work in smokers etc we want to
start to personalize these interventions
so that we can have a better better
efficacy
that sounds really exciting so when
these results come out
what would you regard as being i don't
know like positive results
and given the if there are positive
results what would you do with that
information
in terms of what do you hope to do in
terms of subsequent
trials or investigations yeah i think
that um
well there have been a couple studies
already there was a recent study on
exercise and lifestyle interventions
that showed that
using a methylation clock they could
reverse aging by three years i think
with a
with a short enriched
[Music]
and there was a previous study looking
at three different
uh uh taking three different small
molecules where
nine people did it could reverse
biologic age by a couple years
um those are really small studies
they're not
controlled very well however i think
they're important because they're
suggesting
that it might be possible to reverse
aging at least to some degree
um you know i'm not i'm not going to i'm
not going to say that david beckham is
going to be on the soccer field again
but
but it may be that you know i think a
lot of people thought you could slow
the process but if you slow the process
even with the biomarkers it's a really
hard thing to measure because
you know over six months they don't
change that much
if you can actually reverse them even by
you know two
three five years uh that's a really
exciting finding
that's what these studies are suggesting
and what we need to do now is go back
and do really controlled studies to
validate that
and maybe it is possible to reverse
aging to some degree i think that would
be i think
when i started in the field you know a
lot of people said you'll never
modify aging is too complex
and if you do you'll just slow it down
you'll never reverse it
and now i think most people are saying
it's pop it's possible to slow aging
um but i don't know if you'll be able to
reverse it so i mean we're making
progress i don't know where the end
point is but i'm ex
even if we can extend healthspan by five
years
in the population that's a huge economic
and quality of life benefits so i think
we
set that goal first even if we just get
there we've already done a lot
um you know we're gonna have to do these
studies are relatively small 120 people
or so six month interventions
people 45 to 65. uh if they show really
positive data then one of the things
we'll have to do is to do bigger studies
um to validate and to get more
personalized data
but you know a lot of what we're testing
is supplements and lifestyles so we're
really looking to partner with singapore
government and other agencies here
to scale things into community testing
i would really love for everybody when
they hit a certain age
to get their biologic age measure and if
something as simple as a 3d facial
reconstruction works which is totally
non-invasive
you could imagine that being done when
you go to get your id renewed
right so i'm hopeful that we can really
implement some of these things
and uh start to have an effect and
singapore is an ideal testing ground for
that
huge problem with aging here because uh
you know it's a small island there's not
the reproductive rate is extremely low
and people live a long time so the you
know it's
it's almost like japan in terms of the
percentage of people over the age of 65
a little bit behind but catching up and
so this is a great place to see if we
can really do something about it
cool and that's really exciting to hear
um so one thing that i'm interested in
um as well from the kind of biochemical
perspective
is potentially combining different
interventions together
and so i know in one of the earlier akg
studies they
did it in worms and they found that akg
alone extended
their lifespan but if the worms were
dietary restricted
they didn't see that they didn't see as
much of a benefit
and so i wondered what your thoughts are
on not necessarily just akg but actually
combining different
interventions together and whether or
not they could be synergistic or
potentially detrimental
i i think the i'm positive about this
approach in the long run but right now
i don't think we can predict what's
going to happen we've tested a large
number of combinations of mice
and we do find we've never found
anything that's toxic but we do find
things that cancel each other out
and some things don't seem to interact
at all other things are additive and
i honestly can't predict what's gonna
what's gonna happen when we start the
experiment so
you know there are a lot of hackers out
there that are taking 15 different
things and
and their pills now they're coming out
that give you 12 different things to
slow aging
um i honestly don't know what happens
when you take 12 different things
and i i think that that's where we want
to get to
maybe not 12 but we want to get to
multiple
interventions to maximize the effect but
i don't think we really know how to do
that yet
and the other thing i'll say is if if
you get a pill that has 12
things in it and it's this big
ask yourself how much of each one could
it possibly have
because uh you know the akg bills with
the vitamin a are this big and
they're we'd like to make them smaller
but we have to make them that big to get
the product in
now if you imagine 12 things so i think
that the anti-aging
you know market is still full of a lot
of things that
that probably don't work uh having said
that there are some things that are very
intriguing
the akg the nad precursors and some of
the other stuff
and i think that it's fine for people to
go ahead and start trying things
i encourage them to to be educate
themselves and try things but
you know we have to really validate this
and figure out what's working in the
long run
exactly no i completely agree that was a
really good answer and so the other
thing that
besides you're right about whether or
not combinations would work or not
and it's well talking about different
doses of the
interventions the other thing that i
always find quite interesting to think
about is
the time of day in which an intervention
might be underdone
because the circadian rhythm like
regulates so many different processes
within our bodies
and so i was just wondering have you
looked into whether or not like akg
may be more beneficial if it was done in
the morning or the evening or
anything like that yeah again in the
mice it's in the food so they're getting
a steady dose of it we'd have to change
the dosing strategy which could be done
or we could start to do some testing in
humans as well i think that's a really
good question for any intervention right
now
i mean the other thing is with the akg
we really only tested one dose in the
mice and
and so you know i think that
higher doses may have even more positive
effects that
with akg has been tested up to 10 grams
a day
in another clinical study for
osteoporosis and they found no evidence
of toxicity so
as far as we know there's there's
nothing terribly risky about taking more
so we want to go back and do mouth
studies now that
where we ramp the dose up the other
thing i'll say
dosing is another thing that's very
personalized and if you look at the
vitamin studies like vitamin e and
vitamin a
everybody says we did a meta-analysis
and we don't see any benefit
well i go back and look at those studies
and ask
how many times they actually measure the
levels of vitamin e and vitamin a and
the individuals in the study they just
gave us
a supplement people they took it
and they measured effects they generally
didn't try to optimize the levels of the
vitamins
and so our studies on vitamin a
vitamin a is an interesting molecule
it's beneficial it does a lot of good
things but it
you know people call it a vitamin so
it's safe if you take too much it's
toxic people have known that for a long
time
and so we've been playing around with
the dose in mice and we can get as much
of a 20
lifespan extinction with just vitamin a
but we got to get the dose right
and so what we're doing now is going
back and doing personalized dosing so
each mouse gets a different dose of
vitamin a based on efficacy and toxicity
markers in the blood
and we keep modifying that dose and my
guess is if we can optimize even just
with a set of vitamins
if we can optimize levels we can have a
profound effect on aging
in an individual of course that gets
more expensive right because you have to
monitor the levels of things
but but nonetheless i think that i think
there's a lot of room for improvement
but just
the things that you know vitamins and
things like akg and maybe adp
cursors that you know we haven't really
done any of those kind of dosing
tests or personalized dosing so there's
a lot of room for progress
no exactly and personalized medicine is
something that's also
i find really interesting because you're
right we we're all different we have
different
um genetic variations we all have
different environmental factors that
we're exposed to we do different jobs
we eat different things and so i guess
another question
um is if we're going to kind of strive
for
like personalized medicine what kind of
things would we need to do in terms of
biomarkers
um like i suppose the other way phrasing
it is what would be like the gold
standard for biomarkers to be able to
achieve
personalized medicine yeah i think
that's an interesting question i mean
you could imagine
optimizing the aging biome but one thing
about aging biomarkers is that
we tend to think that biologic aging
behaves like chronologic aging you know
chronic
is just measured by time and goes
steadily up
my guess with these biologic aging
markers is that's not what's happening
that they're oscillating
you know and then depending on how much
sleep you got
you know when you ate healthy did you go
for a run
you have the the virus
and you might have been biologically 10
years different from
one from one two week period to the next
and so i i sort of see it as you know
as you get older that oscillation may be
increasing and eventually you cross some
threshold
and then you're also hyperglycemic or
something you get diabetes so
i think that we really need to look
longitudinally at these biomarkers
because one time point may not give you
a really good
determination of what what your biologic
age is
uh so if you're optimizing to that you
know it might work but the oscillation
may cause problems so
what we're trying to do right now is you
know for things like vitamin a we know
what the toxicity markers are so we look
at those
uh and but we don't really know what
vitamin d does to aging so we're
looking at we're trying to identify the
right efficacy marker too so we're
looking at inflammatory markers and
other things but
um yeah i think that that's one
challenge right now to personalize
drug dosing uh is that we
don't always know what we want to
optimize for in the blood
and so we there's a little bit of
science that has to go in to figure that
out too
so what um are the kind of main
biomarkers that you think at the moment
are
most effective so i know there's a lot
of talk about using the epigenetic
agent clock so would you be able to
explain a bit what that is
yeah so uh you know by even around 2010
everyone was saying
the search for aging biomarkers is
basically a failure
you know we have things like walking
speed and grip strength
and time get up and go and
a few other things that work
particularly well in elderly populations
but in terms of molecular biomarkers
none of them were
that predictive even telomere linked i
mean it does have some
correlation with with life expectancy
but it's not that strong
what happened is that uh people like
steve horvath and others
they started collecting really deep data
sets of
genome-wide dna methylation and then
had the person's age and so they put age
into the computer and then had the
computer use machine learning to
optimize
the the state of methylation and all
these different sites in the genome
to predict a person's age so if your age
is 50 and the biologic age says you're
45
you know that really what that is is the
error in the algorithm
because the algorithm was trying to
predict chronologic age
but the argument is that the error is
there because it's not really can't
really measure
chronological age it's measuring
biologic age and so
what that's saying is that you're
actually aging very well you're only 45
when you actually have lived 50 years
uh and that now there's a whole range of
different
evolved methylation clocks that and
that's one of the things we're using in
singapore i'll say however that
it's still unclear whether there's
anything special about methylate dna
methylation
um there are clocks based on
transcriptomics they're clocks based on
microbiome now they're clocks based on
metabolomics
uh and so it may be that
and like i said there's a facial pattern
clock
it may be that anything that you can get
enough complex data and enough people
and use the right ai you can predict
biologic age from
so i i think that's still an open
question is there anything special about
methylation
um but were you so we're using the
facial pattern stuff we
were doing complete blood counts because
there's a company called gerald that's
helped
can do biologic aids from that data
we're collecting accelerometry data
we're collecting dexa scans
and immune markers and some of the more
classic clinical markers
and the idea is to really merge all that
together and see
you know what what we're getting out of
it and
are we looking at you know several sides
of the same coin are we looking at
completely different things which would
be kind of scary so i hope that's not
the case so
it's um the first step
is really to to bring these different
biomarkers together
and see how they interact that's a
really good answer
so um i agree i think the improvements
as well that
it seems like every every few months has
a like improvement upon these different
clocks in terms of their accuracy and
their ability to
um integrate the different markers
together and so
i guess one um issue in terms of being
able to make
these um biomarkers scalable is to have
a kind of cost-effective
um biomarker and say the facial patterns
is something that anyone could just take
a photo it seems quite easily scalable
but in terms of like these more amex
approaches
how scalable do you think they are
[Music]
well first of all the collab we the
collaborator we work with on the facial
pattern is
jackie han peaking university
and uh it's actually uh was originally
optimized in the han chinese ethnicity
uh the uh it doesn't work with just a
phone picture yet
you need to re do a three-dimensional
reconstruction that your phone
can't fight it's getting close but can't
quite do
so it's not as simple but i think phones
will get there
and you know the technology may improve
to use
phone data as well there are other
people that have tried to generate
clocks from
bone pictures as well the
uh but you know the
you know the other stuff methylation can
now be done from saliva
uh so you know with the with the that's
why we chose the particular methylation
clock we did is you could send an
envelope with a piece of paper
along with akg this is for the company
and you can spit on the piece of paper
and send it back in and the dna is
stable and you know so that's
not that's very scalable uh if you have
to take a blood draw it gets a little
bit more complicated
and we've just completely rejected
anything that requires biopsies because
while they may be more informative i can
certainly do a lot with biopsies
i can't people aren't going to get
muscle biopsies i
just won't do it so and you can't scale
it anyway
so it it's i think that we're willing to
look at those more complex things or
things like dexa scanning but
that's really for more for research
purposes the main goal of the biomarkers
is
you know again something that everybody
can do
cool so um in terms of our future
research are there any particularly
i know any particular areas that you
think are very promising in terms of
discovering
new potential interventions or improving
our understanding of aging
um for example um like regenerative
medicine approaches
is there anything you've kind of got
your eye on that you think looks very
promising
yeah um you know i think that there's a
lot of futuristic things
gene therapy returning medicine and
we don't have any idea yet what can we
accomplish there reprogramming you know
there are studies now saying that you
can reprogram adult cells and that has
an effect on aging
uh there's certainly some potential
risks there but i think that that could
in theory that could cause a dramatic
change to
life expectancy uh so i think that we'll
continue to get new and better and
technologically advanced things uh one
of the things that i want to
study right now are mesical stem cells
because people go get these treatments
all over the world pay a lot of money
and um a lot of people will tell you
they
have tremendous effect on their aging
and their inflammation and things like
that
so but there really aren't any good
biomarker studies on aging so we're
looking to partner with a company to try
to achieve that now we may not be able
to do
a full placebo control study but at
least we can baseline it and look at the
follow-up because
you can easily imagine how something
like mesenchymal stem cells and
the factors that these cells secrete
that are anti-inflammatory and stimulate
your own adult stem cells
might be beneficial in it you know so i
think that
right now i'm still trying to corral all
the potential interventions out there
and see what works
and i but i think there are a lot of
exciting things that may have
you know rapamycin is probably the gold
standard right now
uh but it may be trivial compared to
what can be done in 10 or 15 years
the field's really taking off uh and
there's a lot of
private sector money in it now which is
great so it allows
crazy companies doing different things
and um
it's a little bit the wild west but some
of these things are going to work so
uh i'm excited to see where the field
goes
good answer i'm so could you actually
explain a bit more and for those who
don't know what
messenger stem cells actually are um
what
what are they proposed to do yeah so
these are stem cells that are isolated
from bone marrow or other part
other places in your body um they uh
respond to damage or injury uh home to
those sites
and they have an anti-inflammatory
secrete factors that are
anti-inflammatory
they may in to some extent in the in in
your body contribute to repair of the
tissue but it looks like that they're
not they don't have such a big role in
that it's more
stimulating the local cells to do the
repair
um they are somewhat imma
immune protected so when you get an
injection of them you don't have to have
your own cells
uh and so a lot of these companies now
are taking like cells from umbilical
cord
isolating the mscs and the umbilical
cord growing them out and injecting them
into
people um and
you know that i think that there were a
lot of there was a lot of hope initially
that when you put these cells in they
would actually
there was a lot of studies like in heart
failure you know and they were hoping
that they would engraft into the heart
and replace the damaged tissue and that
didn't really happen but what
they found was that these cells actually
had a beneficial effect even though they
weren't grafting
so that's when people started looking at
these factors that are secreted
and so they hang around in the body for
a period of time it depends on who you
talk to
maybe up to six months and um
and and they may be providing some
really beneficial effects but
like i said you know a lot of athletes
take them for soft tissue repair they
stimulate
muscle repair but we don't have
i don't think really good aging data yet
so it would be
interesting to find out if it's really
affecting biologic age
cool so we've spoken a lot about a lot
of
um exciting uh areas of current research
um in terms of different interventions
but in addition to like the exciting
work are there any major hurdles that
the field kind of still faces in general
like funding
being one of them well government
funding is always still lagging behind
it's there's still a lack of awareness
that aging is something we need to deal
with
it's probably the most important thing
to deal with i mean the whole
most of the medical world is focused
around sick care
where do you get some chronic disease
and we try to treat it and that costs a
lot it's not that effective
but people make a lot of money off of it
and so there's an entrenched system
to to treating people and
converting more to preventative medicine
and health care is a real
challenge you know that the system is
not set up to deal with that it's hard
to do clinical studies
the pharmaceutical companies you know if
we kept everybody healthy all their
drugs for sick people wouldn't make any
money anymore so they're
you know they look the field is full of
people that want to do good but they're
also driven by money
and so you know it's a it's a challenge
to really
convert back to a health care system you
know i tell people when i get sick i
want to be treated
but i'd rather just not get sick and
i think it's going to be easier to slow
aging than it is to treat most of these
diseases of aging
but we have to commit to it and there's
not enough government funding right now
the other challenge is that aging's
still not recognized as a disease
you know it it's really crazy right when
you think about it
cancer affects a third of the population
and we spend trillions of dollars trying
to do something about it
aging affects a hundred percent of the
population we're like it's natural
it's it's like you know if buses ran
over
30 percent of the population and trucks
hit 100
we regulate the buses you know it
doesn't make any sense
uh and so but that's you know i think
people
spent thousands of years rationalizing
aging
and oh it's good it gives you wisdom and
there's religious arguments for it and
it's natural and i think we need to
let that go i mean you i think we can
get wisdom as experience right if we can
slow aging we can have people with a lot
of wisdom that are still young
and so um so i think we need to
just change that mindset make
aging a recognized target for
intervention
and and also just take a full life
course approach to health care
you know i think that if you know i walk
by the hippocratic oath there's a big
statue of in u.s medical school
and this is a great document okay but
the way it's interpreted now
is maybe not quite right you know the
first thing people say when you ask what
that means is first do no harm
and the way they interpret that is that
if someone's healthy we shouldn't really
take any risks with them because
you know we can only do harm but i don't
think anybody's completely healthy
you know if you have somebody that's 40
and doesn't meet the criteria for
clinical diagnosis of disease
there's still a lot you can do to help
those people and by doing nothing you're
probably harming them
so i think that we need to we need to
take more of a life course approach to
medicine
we need to encourage healthy lifestyles
very early in life
maybe look at supplements as you
approach middle age
and maybe even more radical things as
you get closer to getting chronic
diseases or even
people that already have chronic
diseases potentially
and and if we do that we'll have a much
bigger impact on health span in the long
run
that's a really nice way of describing
it so um where would you
hope healthcare to be in let's say 10
years time
i would love to see widespread adoption
of strategies to extend health span
um and you know you can argue that
already sort of exists you know like the
health promotion board here has an app
that they give out and wearables that
they give out to try to encourage people
to take more steps so
from a lifestyle perspective people are
already trying things
the problem is that getting people to do
sustainable lifestyle change is
not easy but people are trying those
things but i'd like to see supplements
and even drugs added to that list
so um we can really try to
have i think i think it's totally
feasible to
affect health spend by five to ten years
uh but
it has to be something that someone's
willing to commit to
and really make the effort and
ultimately the
it has to be a combination of private
and public sector approaches to solve
this problem
and so there's still that battle of
changing the mindset
of saying that you know just because
everybody ages doesn't make it something
you want to do
and you know and so i i
i still i think the whole field is still
struggling to get that message across
so speaking of interventions is there
any advice that you'd give to people now
if they wanted to
help improve like their health span or
their health in general what would you
advise
yeah i always sound like your mother
when i answer this
yeah they're really four things that you
can do right now i mean
if you want to try supplements great
triumph
we're still finalizing this validation
on a lot of things but there's a lot of
potential candidates
but outside of that it's about lifestyle
and there's really four factors
there's exercise some combination of
cardiovascular
resistance exercise with resistance
training
healthy diet which we could talk all day
about but you know don't eat too many
calories that's a good start
maybe consider some of these
intermittent fasting strategies
and then i would argue to have a
balanced portions of macronutrients in
your diet
stress it's kind of hard to study this
in animals but i think the amount of
stress you feel is a big driver of aging
and then sleep which is not that easy to
modify sometimes but sleep quality
declines with age and i think it's
important to
try to mitigate that but you know the
question is how do you do that
and ultimately it has to be changes you
could make that are sustainable which
means that you enjoy them
you know if i tell you to be a vegan
marathon runner you're probably not
going to do it
so yeah i think it really takes people
to think about their it's personalized
people should think about their lives
look at where they can start to make
slow changes uh that are
toward health and i think if they do
that
you know it's kind of it'll keep growing
because what you'll realize is you feel
better now
not just 20 years from now and that's
especially true of exercise there's a
there's a there's a threshold you have
to get over before you really feel the
benefits of it
if you don't exercise and you start
running or doing something the first two
months
is mostly misery you know but
once you get over a certain threshold
then you find that it feels good to run
you know and it actually is takes away
stress to run and
it gives you more energy and so but you
have to get over those barriers
the same thing is true of like taking
sugar out of your diet if you
talk to people that switch from coke to
diet coke
they hate the diet coke at the beginning
and eight weeks later they hate the coke
because it's way too sweet you know but
it takes time your body doesn't
transition quickly so
it's about sustainability and that's
that's the key for lifestyle
that's really great advice so um thank
you very much for taking the time to
speak with me today
it's been great to kind of pick your
brain and to find out a lot more about
these clinical trials that you're
conducting in singapore
so um um unless you have any final words
it's just i've been fantastic to have
you on
the show today no no i just thanks for
having me and it's great you're doing
this show i think it's wonderful
thank you very much so i really hope
you've enjoyed listening to this
interview and i've learned something
today
i want to say thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening